because they don't make homeless people  the way they made him when i was a kid  you know  when i was a kid a homeless guy was a  bum he was a vagrant somebody down on  his luck or whatever you know a wino  they didn't have this shutter island  [ __ ]  going on that they had out there like  people talking to trees  you like right here having like eggs  benedict  he's like looking through a porthole  over your cabbage when i was a kid you  can only be crazy outside for about 15  minutes before a van would pull up  and two guys in nurses outfits would  just come walking out hey buddy how's it  going  you're making a lot of racket out here  aren't you  why don't you do me a favor try this  shirt on you're like okay  how come the sleeves are so long  oh because we're going to tie your arms  behind your back because you're out of  your [ __ ] mind that's it